you
[Music]
I'm software at my name is Jim I'm a
software engineer at our studio today I
wanted to have a dialogue about
dependencies so first some ground rules
so all our code has dependencies even if
your our code is just and so those are
like treats so that dog is very well
trained they all our code has
dependencies even if your code is just
an R script and depends on nothing but
base our base R itself depends on system
libraries and those depend on the
compiler control chain that was used and
ultimately the Machine that the code is
running on so you really you cannot get
away from fun dependencies and the flip
side of that is dependencies inevitably
break so this cat is being you know like
cats are sometimes and and destroying
the tower so some examples of this in
the JavaScript community are the left
pad package was removed by the
maintainer from the from the repository
and and destroyed a bunch of websites
like millions of websites and another
example is the event stream package had
a malicious maintainer that added
credential harvesting code to the to the
package and those are like actively
malicious actors maintained errs but the
the more common phenomenon is is bit rot
where you have your code works fine some
time passes the dependencies changed and
now your code no longer works so and in
addition to this there's often this case
so this is a xkcd of Python the various
methods that you can install packages in
Python and and when this when people run
into these installation problems and
dependency problems they this is
colloquially termed dependency hell and
often people when they encounter this
they there's a sort of a movement to a
less is more approach for dependencies
and while I think this philosophy is
really nice for architecture
I don't really feel like this is a great
solution to the problem in software and
why is this primarily because I don't
think you can treat all dependencies as
equivalent and sort of to illustrate
this point let's go through some
dependencies so this is looking at the
cran landing pages just that cran
provides and this package is the R Lang
package we can see it depends only on R
itself it doesn't depend on any
additional packages in contrast to that
this is the cnv scope package and this
this package now depends on over 40
other packages which themselves depend
on additional packages and this is
depending on packages not just on cran
but also on bioconductor so clearly we
shouldn't be treating these two packages
as equivalent in this respect as another
aspect of how package differ this is the
so cran provides on their on their
landing page the check results for all
packages and in those check results the
column I'm highlighting is the mean time
are the median time to install those
packages on Crayons build machines so
this is the glue package I maintain you
can see the time to install is very
short for this package now this is the
read our package that I also maintain
and you can see these these installation
times are much much higher so the glue
installation times were only 5 to 10
seconds I guess Windows is slow so it
was 24 but the read our package is much
much higher so these are well over 200
all the way up to 700 seconds so clearly
we cannot treat glue and read are the
same in terms of this aspect another
aspect that is useful is the the binary
size of the package so typically when
users are installing packages they're
installing binaries from cran and
there's a wide range of the size of
those binaries so the AWS PAC package is
the smallest package on cran it has its
sizes less than 10 kilobytes in contrast
each
two packages over a hundred megabytes in
size and if you go and look at the
bioconductor repositories the largest
binary package and bioconductor is over
four gigabytes in size so clearly we
cannot cannot treat a 4 gigabyte package
and a 10 kilobyte page is the same
another aspect is how hard it is to
install the system requirements for a
package so often so most packages only
depend on our itself to install they
don't have any compiled code so they
only need our you don't even need an
additional compiler or a tool chain in
contrast so this is the our GDI package
and it depends it has extensive system
requirements that are very hard to
configure so this whole paragraph at the
bottom is is the instructions on what
you need to do to install and configure
the system dependencies for this package
another good example is our friend our
Java so so there's not one not two but
three Stack Overflow posts all with
about a hundred upvotes
of people having problems installing or
you're running our Java and on Windows
Mac OS and Linux so clearly this is a
package that it's not as easy to install
and use as some other packages so all
this is to show you that we should not
be treating dependencies as equivalent
you cannot say a package has ten
dependencies and it's clearly the same
as in a different package that also has
ten dependencies we need to treat these
things differently so what should we do
instead so I think really when you're
deciding whether or not to have a
dependency in your package or to use a
certain package because it has so many
dependencies you need to weigh some
things and this how this the scale works
that really depends on your your your
personal use case and and the users of
your of your codes so if you're so if
you have more dependencies you gain more
features more bug fixes more testing of
those of those features because
other users are using your dependent
dependencies but you but if you don't if
you have fewer dependencies you instead
have a last installation time last you
use less disk space you potentially have
less breakage in your code because you
don't depend on an external package so
having more dependencies gives you more
developer time so it takes you less you
as the developer less time but you lose
generality so really I think you need to
consider your users as like the as when
you're making these decisions if the
package you're writing or the project
you're using is really meant for other
package developers to include your
package in in theirs the installation
time becomes more of a factor so that so
it's more costly if if other packages
are trying to depend on your package and
in addition smaller more focused package
the packages are easy too easier to
include and depend on than larger
broader packages and in this context I
think stability is often more important
than features it's more important if the
if this the package is stable over time
then if it continually gains new
additional features in contrast if your
users are primarily other data
scientists or statisticians that are
loading your package in our scripts the
installation time in that case is very
cheap so those people are probably going
to install your package once or just a
handful of times and often if you're
depending on other packages that are
widely that are highly used in the
community those packages often are
already installed already so the users
don't even have to install those most
for the most time for the most part and
in this case in this context the really
the features are the most important
thing you need to worry about so if your
code is really meant more in this this
context you're more likely to include
additional dependencies in addition once
you sort of decide that you want to
replace the given dependency is
important to take
into account this phenomenon of
illusionary superiority so people just
as a whole and I include myself in this
I have a very hard time rating
themselves against the rest of of the
populations so some examples are like in
teaching ability there was a survey done
in the University of nebraska-lincoln
faculty and they were supposed to rate
their teaching ability versus the rest
of the faculty and in this survey 68% of
them responded that they were in the top
25% of the faculty so in another example
in driving skill so ninety-three percent
of us respondents to the survey and 69
percent of Swedish respondents put them
in the top fifty percent of drivers so
clearly a lot of people are vastly
overrated
their own abilities so how this relates
to this this issue is don't just because
you think you might be good at
programming and that the problem maybe
doesn't seem that hard you're off you're
you're very likely to overrate have the
difficulty of the problem and sort of
your own ability to produce reproduce
the results of the dependency you're
trying to replace so really avoid so
some pitfalls of removing dependencies
this avoid this over estimation of
abilities and people often underestimate
how easy it is to introduce new bugs I
guess I've been programming long enough
that I just assume I will be introducing
new bugs when I rewrite in code it's
just like you do your best to avoid it
but it it just seems like is inevitable
it always happens in addition a benefit
of using widely use packages is not that
necessarily those the authors of those
packages are better or worse at
programming than you might be but
because they're widely used they have a
huge user base and those users are
uncovering bugs which can then be fixed
so really having of using widely use
packages is a great way to sort of have
free tests in your package and really
the sort of the conclusion of all of
this is that less is not always more
two dependencies so when you're trying
when you've decided that your package or
project has too many dependencies and
you're trying to remove it how do you
know what dependencies you're you want
to remove in this I think it's really
important not to just trust your gut in
this I think you need to quantify sort
of the weight of each dependency unready
to figure out which one you should
actually remove and how do you do that
so I have this package on github it
depends that is is really aimed to make
it to be a toolbox for for making these
types of decisions so what what does
this package do so it it does a few
things so first it lets you assess the
usage of all the dependencies in your
package or project second it lets you
measure each of those dependencies
measure the weights of these
dependencies against some of the things
that we should that I showed you earlier
in addition it lets you visualize all of
your dependencies so they so you can
easily see which ones are taking the
majority of the time like installation
time or or binary size and finally it
has tools to locate and and assist
removing dependencies so I'll go through
all of these in turns
so first the DEP uses product uses
package functions lets you determine how
you're using dependencies in your
project or package so you basically call
this and it returns a table of all of
the calls for each package and for each
dependency package in your project and
then I can just count them with D PI R
and get a a nice count of for each
package how many function calls have I
used from that package so we're using
the base package in this project a bunch
the na road here is functions that I've
declared inside my project and then
we're using per and glue a bunch as well
maybe I want to see which functions from
those dependency packages I'm using the
most so this is basically this is doing
some other deep liar
relations to show you that and and this
is basically showing the top function
for each of the dependency packages so
and we can do some others so that was
with prod that was for projects now we
can do the same thing for a package so
this is using DEP uses package on the
dev tools package to count which
dependencies I'm using within dev tools
so here we have without 3,000 function
calls from the base package 362 function
calls from functions defined in the dev
tools package itself and then we're
using get to our use this package load
so we can easily see which dependencies
we're using the most and so so this is
very useful to see which pack which
dependencies maybe we're not using very
much and would be easier to remove so
once you've sort of whittled it down
your full list of dependencies and
decide and targeted those you might want
to remove how do you figure out which
ones way more or less we can use the DEF
weight function to do this so this
returns a table of 25 different so it's
25 columns so 24 different aspects that
the dependencies can can vary on so here
I'm weighing two packages D PI R and
data table and and we're getting a large
result of different weights I can go and
we'll go through some of these they
don't all fit on one slide obviously so
some examples of things that returns so
num user is the number of user
dependencies so these are dependencies
that a user would install on none dev is
the number of development dependencies
so a developer of these packages would
install these but users typically
wouldn't the binary self and binary user
in binary dev is the binary sizes for
this the South the user dependencies and
the development dependencies and then
they install columns or the mean time or
the median time to install each of those
packages and and all of the the user in
dev is the all of the dependency
packages
so those are the times to that cran did
to install install those dependencies so
this makes it very easy to tell which
which packages have more dependencies
and heavier weight dependencies some
other things that the DEF weight
function returns is the number of
functions in the package so this gives
you a idea of sort of the breadth of the
package and also if you contrast the
number of functions in the package with
the number of functions you're using in
your package you get some sense of sort
of how much of the dependency package
you're actually using if a dependency
package is very big and you're only
using a small subset of that package
maybe you can it's easier to remove that
dependency other things that this
returns is the number of weekly
downloads so that's what's in the
download column the time of the first
crane release and the latest cran
release and the number of releases in
the last 50 to 52 weeks so these all
give you some idea of sort of the age
and maturity of the package as well as
sort of how often is being updated on
cran it also returns some information if
the package is on github so this is
returning the number of open issues in
each package the number of stars Forks
and when it was last updated again so
again this gives you some idea of sort
of the development speed of the package
and but you can see both of these
packages are widely used and have been
updated very frequently so once you've
done this waiting often it's useful to
visualize all the dependencies against
each of your of your package or project
against each other and see see which
dependencies are really taking up the
bulk of the time so this plot is showing
the the dependencies of the deploy our
package and the labels are probably too
small to read but so the left side the
left facet is yes left left facet is
using the is showing the user
dependencies so these are the
dependencies that a user would typically
install the right one is showing the
development dependents
and if we just focus on the user
dependencies we can see this is this is
installation time so the installing deep
liar building deep liar itself is the
thing that takes the vast majority of
the installation time for deep liar if
we change this to looking at the binary
size the pictures kind of changes so now
the BH package is actually the bulk of
the time installing the binary the
binary of that package is much bigger
than the deep layer itself so now we've
sort of targeted using these tools we
can kind of target which dependencies
might be the most beneficial to remove
and so once we've decided to do this how
do you actually remove a dependency so
first I think the most important thing
is to write extents it like much many
more tests than you would normally write
with the dependency in place in your
package to make sure you're not
introducing any new bugs you will
probably introduce new bugs anyway but
really like try to write tons of tests
to avoid this and then only then will
then try to replace the dependency and
the it depends package gives you a nice
tool to help find all the uses of the
package in-depth locate so if you use
this and now you look trying to locate
all of the per dependencies in this tiny
verse dashboard project and if you run
this on the normal our console you get a
nice printout of every location of a
call to the per package so this makes it
very easy to find and remove them and if
you then use this in inside the our
Studio IDE you it takes advantage of the
marker pane in the IDE and you get very
nice output and you can actually double
click on each of these lines in the
marker pane and the ID will take you
directly to that line so it makes it
very easy to find and remove a given
dependency so in conclusion this it
depends package is really a toolbox to
let you find all measure the usage of
your dependency way each of those
dependencies plot them and
locate them and the sort of big big
point takeaways to this is don't treat
dependencies as equivalent you really
have to measure and balance and sort of
you and weigh the pros and cons of
having a dependency really be where your
own over confidence in your ability to
replace the dependency and less and the
sort of overall conclusion is less is
not always more so thank you everyone
and the slides are are there
thank you very much Jim thank for that
introduction we don't really have time
for questions but people probably wanted
to start changing rooms but if you have
quick questions do one sentence with a
question mark just over there gentleman
with a black shirt on good throw thank
you and Jim would this also work or will
it work at some point in my shiny app
yes so the project versions should work
like the project versions of all of
those examples should work exactly the
same in the shiny app as they would a
regular our project so it's really just
looking at any of the our files under
that directory so that should work just
fine and defining app yeah thanks thank
you
you
[Music]